(chanting)
- Forced marriage, child
marriage, these are real
problems here in the
United States and nobody
else is paying any attention to this.
We like to think of the United States
as being far advanced when it comes
to women's rights and girl's rights,
but, in the decade 2000
to 2010, almost a quarter
of a million children were
married in the United States
and nobody was talking about this.
Child marriage right now
is legal in 48 U.S. states.
Is that okay?
- [Group] No!
- Somebody needed to do something.
I stepped up because I have been through
it myself, and I wanted to help.
(light music)
I grew up in the ultra-Orthodox
Jewish community,
which is a very insular
religious community.
I always knew that I would marry young,
and it would be a marriage
that would be arranged for me.
I was a clueless 19-year-old.
I was so happy on my wedding day.
I was doing everything
that I had always been told
I wanted to do, and then
it took exactly one week
for that all to come crashing down.
My then husband flew into
this, you know, violent rage,
and then he threatened to
kill me for the first time.
It was a reality check for me.
You know, it's painful but,
you know, the pain you
go through is part of
what makes you who you are.
I finally put a plan in place to get
out when I was 27 because at that point
things had gotten so bad.
So it was a five year escape plan.
It was terrifying and so lonely, and there
was no one who supported me.
Everyone I knew had declared me dead.
And everyone in the
outside world could not
possibly understand this
process that I was going
through; but, I got
divorced, and I was able to
rebuild my life from scratch.
There are so many other women and girls
who end up getting stuck
in an abusive relationship
and I thought, I need to
help them get to where
I was able to get somehow.
Unchained At Last is the
only organization that
is dedicated to ending
forced and child marriage
in the United States
through direct services
and through advocacy.
So the first thing that we
do when somebody reaches out
to us for help is we make sure that they
are someplace safe.
Coordinating escapes is
one of the key services
that we provide.
We provide free legal representation
through our team of pro bono attorneys
and then I'll provide emotional support
and anything else to these women.
There are many, many different reasons
that parents will force an adult
or a minor child to marry.
Certainly culture, religion, tradition,
you know, is one of those reasons,
but it's not the only one.
For example, you know, a
child comes out as LGBTQ
or a girl gets pregnant
and the family says,
we're gonna respond to this
with a forced marriage.
I mean this is not just
happening in any one community.
- I grew up with a very abusive father.
He wanted me to be with
someone he could control.
If it weren't for Fraidy,
I would probably be living
a very different life
and an arranged marriage.
- Fraidy is the most
compassionate, gentle,
sensitive person, and she
will keep fighting for you,
even when you lose the fight.
When you feel like you have
no fight left inside yourself.
She's actually making a
difference and spreading awareness
in a way that can save so many people from
going through the experiences
that I went through.
- I founded Unchained in 2011.
Since then, we have
helped about 500 people
to escape forced marriages.
But more and more girls
under 18 were reaching
out to ask for help and we realize,
under 18, there's almost
nothing legally that we can do
to help these girls.
Really the only way to help
them is to change the laws.
In many states, the loopholes
in their marriage age laws
were so gaping that they didn't specify
any minimum age for marriage.
Thanks to your leadership,
we're really, really
hopeful that we can finally end child
marriage in the United States.
(clapping)
We finally had our first victory.
Delaware became the first U.S.
state to end child marriage.
And then, soon thereafter,
New Jersey became
the second state - no
marriage before age 18.
(clapping)
We're using the democratic process.
We are raising awareness, and
we're meeting with legislators
one at a time; and we hold these chain-ins
as a form of protest that we invented
where we gather and we all
wear bridal gowns and veils,
and we chain our wrists
to show legislators
this is what life looks
like for a girl or a woman
who is forced to marry.
Every time I'm able to
help somebody whose going
through what I went through,
that never gets old;
that feeling, it's so
healing and empowering.
And for all those that I couldn't help,
especially the children, those under 18,
where there was nothing that we could do,
passing those laws to end child marriage,
it's, you know, my message to them,
I'm sorry I couldn't help you, but
this will never happen again,
at least in this state.
Until I am too old to
wear my heels anymore
and too old to put on my red lipstick
in the morning, I am
going to be still fighting
to end forced and child
marriage in the United States,
still helping the individuals
who are affected by it
and still pushing for policy
change and legal change,
and we're not giving up.
(dramatic music)